et pour en parler l'économiste philippe
mur est avec nous sur ce plateau
philippe furrer bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
alstom devient donc le numéro deux
mondial dans le secteur ferroviaire
c'est un beau coup au fond face aux
concurrents étrangers
ah oui par rapport à l'opération alstom
siemens ou siemens avec des capitaux
allemand racheté alstom avec tous les
risques de délocalisation d'usinés et
d'emplois là c'est un joli coup en plus
c'est une opération équilibrée
ce sont deux entreprises relativement
saine qu'on le même chiffre d'affaires
alstom va garder les usines à au canada
et aussi en france
il est qu'ils ont donc c'est une
opération intéressante équilibrée avec
un petit point de détail quand même
c'est que les québécois et le
gouvernement du québec a fait très
attention il prend 18 % du capital du
nouvel ensemble
alstom bombardier pour que les usines
restent bien au québec et ça il faudrait
que la france fasse la même chose
reprennent la part de bruit qui veut
sortir de alstom pour que la france ait
aussi des parts et pèse autant qu'il
faut pas qu alstom bombardier deviennent
canadien est ce que on pourrait craindre
néanmoins malgré cette bonne opération
une vague peut être massive de
licenciement avec cette fusion
tout ce qu'on peut dire c'est que le pdg
a expliqué qu'ils avaient pas de
redondance et donc qui aurait pas de
pertes d'emplois
les deux entreprises sont
complémentaires en termes de zones
géographiques et donc a priori ya pas de
redondance et il n'y a pas de souci
là-dessus alors il faut encore attendre
le feu vert de l'autorité européenne
dont le disais à l'instant pour nous
éclairer qu'est ce qu'elle doit vérifier
ce que elle peut faire encore
obstruction à ce projet elle peut
toujours faire obstruction parce que la
sainte concurrence et la bible de
l'union européenne
mais en fait il un vrai on peut regarder
les l'opération de cette manière là en
gros alstom bombardier fera 15 milliard
de chiffre d'affaires alors que crc le
chinois fait 30 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires 30 milliards d'euros
donc si on dit alstom bombardier n'a pas
le droit de se créer parce que ça posera
un problème de concurrence
ça veut dire que le chinois n'a pas le
droit de vendre chez nous parce que ça
poserait un problème de concurrence
aussi et s'il croit que c'est là dessus
que le gouvernement français doit se
défendre en expliquant voilà en plus de
cela il ya autre chose c'est que le
chinois à 30 milliards d'euros chiffre
d'affaires en chine est en fait
principalement chine il a tous ses
marchés publics qui sont réservées à lui
donc pourquoi ouvrir le marché européen
du rail qui est réservée qui devrait
être réservé aux européens pourquoi
l'ouvrir aux chinois alors qu'eux mêmes
se réservent leur marché line absences
devraient être ses prostituées naïveté
qui pose un vrai problème
et dernière chose là l'union européenne
allait s'y rattachent les racheter le
fabricant de locomotives oslo par cette
boîte qui fait 30 mire de chiffre
d'affaires donc ça pose et ils n'ont pas
trouvé de problème là-dessus
pourquoi à l'époque d'ailleurs l'union
européenne s'étaient opposés au rachat
de à la fusion de alstom et siemens
ils sont opposés parce qu'il trouvait
qu'en termes de ça ça limitait la
compétition sur le continent mais il
faut qu'elle soit cohérente la
commission européenne si elle veut pas
que le elle peut dire effectivement on
veut pas de fusion elle sonne sims dans
ce cas là on fait pas rentrer crc sur
notre marché
ça c'est très important et serein tout
ça ça va avoir un impact
moi je pense très important pour la
transition écologique parce qu'il faut
savoir que alstom
en fait est le premier constructeur qui
a mis un train à hydrogène sur les rails
et il en a vendu une trentaine à
l'allemagne il y en a déjà qui
fonctionne justement il en a vendu à
l'allemagne pourquoi pas en france
aurait pu être la france la terre
d'accueil de ces nouveaux trains et
hydrogène finalement vous avez tout vous
avez tout à fait raison pourquoi pas en
france parce que peut-être qu'on a plus
data stratège on n'a plus de vision
stratégique et une vraie politique
industrielle là dessus parce que ce
qu'on pourrait faire
c'est que toutes les locomotives diesel
il y en a encore beaucoup en france tout
le réseau électrifié sur les petites
lignes notamment tous ces locomotives
diesel pour être remplacée un grand plan
à 5 10 ans par des locomotives à
hydrogène
alstom avec un intérêt très important
c'est que ça ferait croître l'écosystème
hydrogène en france on pourrait ensuite
mettre les bus à hydrogène dans toutes
les villes comme paris qui étouffe sous
les particules fines ou lyon est ensuite
utilisé tout cet écosystème pour aller
beaucoup plus loin pour aller travailler
que le constructeur automobile pour
mettre en place des voitures à hydrogène
des scooters à hydrogène en france et là
on aurait on ferait politique
industrielle emploi transition
écologique je pense que tout le monde
serait ravie merci beaucoup
philippe erreur d'avoir partagé votre
analyse sur notre plateau je rappelle
que vous êtes économiste un merci